Aaron's on the line in Seattle hi Aaron
how are you I'm good Dave
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
so I'm trying to decide if I should buy
a newer car than the one I I've been
driving for almost 15 years Wow
you have the money I'm having a heart
what's that you have the money uh we
have our six months and then I I was
looking to spend around 12,000 but I'm
just having a hard time you have the
12,000 about him
yeah the 12,000 above the six months ah
okay
cool all right so you're going to move
up from a beater to a $12,000 car and
pay cash oh yeah okay and your household
a hard time well my beater it's funny
because I hear you say people you know
feel like you should drive like a
whatever mine is a 98 Honda Civic with
220,000 miles on it but something just
is never complain it so it's not about
car man it's a good car car probably
another hundred thousand miles on it but
the question is at this point you moving
up is what's called a want you have
basic transportation but there's nothing
evil about spending money on a want that
you have the money that's the first
prerequisite so what is your household
income 100k and what's the other car
worth uh my wife's car yeah we paid off
what's it worth much brand-new which we
should it's worth thirty thousand okay
yeah you need to move up in car okay the
rule of thumb is don't have more than
half your annual income tied up in cars
or things with motors in them that go
down in value
you wouldn't be violating that and and
you're paying cash is rule number two
you wouldn't be violating that and so
you're going to have a small percentage
of your life tied up in this car and
it's reasonable to move up to a twelve
thousand dollar car you make a hundred K
and get out of what is probably a two
thousand dollar car right yeah yeah I
would
okay does that help
perfect yes thanks to the called it open
phones a triple eight eight two five
five two two five here's the thing you
got a room
wealthy people invest in things that go
up in value broke people buy things that
go down in value and call them
investments televisions furniture
jewelry cars boats sea dues and their
sisters because you could have to write
there's nothing wrong with any of those
things I own every one of those things
but they're a very small percentage of
my world and one of the things I
discovered when I went broke and start
studying all rich people is they put
money in things that you don't see
mm-hmm because they don't care what you
think they don't run their life to
impress other people so they put money
and investments that go up in value now
so when we put money in something that
goes down in value we are consuming that
like even travel I'm going to go on
vacation that's a consumption item
there's nothing wrong with that but it
needs to be a small enough percentage of
your world that you're still doing the
investing buying things that go up and
value all you buy is things that go down
in value you are broke and you will
continue to be broke and by the way you
should continue to be broke because
you're stupid and I've been stupid I
don't know what it looks like this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you enjoyed that video
from the Dave Ramsey show if you want to
watch another great video check out my
video three things you should consider
renting right over here or click the
link in the description below
you